everywhere you look at it it's you know
very problematic people are waiting to
get you know their degrees find out jobs
and things like that it's extremely
worrying and especially after four years
of you know within my year group have
been a university since 2019 the first
semester was the only term that hasn't
been affected by some kind of strike
actually it's so so disappointing I mean
I love being an Edinburgh I've Loved
going to University here but the actual
academic experience not through any
fault of my actual tutors but because of
you know the four years I've it's been
an extremely tarnished in that respect
you know quite a lot of jobs you need a
certain degree so many people in this
limbo whereby they're potentially not
going to find out um and it's really
problematic also for kind of students
going on Years Years abroad who infer
that second year you sometimes feel like
foreign universities you need certain
requirements and things like that it's
really whichever way you look at that
look at it it's um extremely damaging